welcome to this video playing Maradona
from Iceland no all on islands he's got
very high rating this guy is a better
run here let let us check five minute
29,000 games and he's nearing his his
top okay I I remember his playing a
king's indian ok I want to try something
else the fianchetto system just to get
some some different position type with a
six I don't I don't really know that
line there are the Gallagher variation
if you play with a four I don't really
know about that there is no safe way to
play this I believe maybe he'll be one
is displayed c5 night back p 5 I don't
know really and then be five year this
is bad luck I try out some some new line
from my repertoire and he's playing one
of the sharpest responses can i play
maybe 95 and some more simplify simplify
matters a bit maybe here exchanging some
stuff that's not very ambitious and no
but I don't I knew that the main lines
are very very sharp and I rather play
this is kind of boring equal position
than something that I have no idea about
maybe this isn't so bad actually I have
a good term I'm quicker in development
he lost some time with this stuff Queen
f6 I have Quincy 8 for instance and he's
in this awkward pin and it's now rookie
to maybe like a look here Bishop d7
Bishop f1 now it's not really helping
much maybe maybe I start with this yeah
maybe
rookie 2 rookies seven looky 21 getting
control over the evo x now i can take a
stupid very stupid so I could have taken
now on c4 look is seven where is he
going after that rook to e8 I can take I
can take here just moving we need to
move the bishop black resign when I was
a lucky win especially here ruki to a
could have taken on c4 I don't think
here here there is so much so much
happening I may be looking to was ok
comp comp wants to play this interesting
I think something like Queenie 3c3
should be about equal and thought that
this would be okay for black why I mean
okay it's wrong like better hook like
opening the be foul this is what the
computer is giving and then this this
idea with equal maybe my bishop looks
like a little bit of a dummy looking at
the sea for pound he's got the better
bishop in regards to the pawn structure
but maybe there is not much there's not
enough going on here that anybody can
can do much you know I was lucky that he
blundered this but then my whole problem
was this opening line which is a very
sharp you went to see six since they
also be far
if I don't there is stuff like b5 here
but maybe maybe here at four is good
this is some of course winning and PSM
and maybe 96 is right I don't know I
don't know how this is played it's a
very very sharp line 95 was a yeah very
M yeah a bit of a bit of a lame move but
I wanted a single position on i.t fire
seems to be better intending this and b5
yeah black is better here also Bishop f5
a 95 this was wasn't a good idea was
lucky that he didn't really exploit it
okay thanks for watching